Etymology and homology
explores the history and
development of individual words,
the origins of a languages,
lexical items.
It asks a question you're likely familiar
with that question is where did this
word come from?
You've probably encountered etymologies
when someone explained the meaning of a
word or when you sought out the origin
of a word for yourself as a linguistic
study.
This question is approached methodically,
so it requires that we understand the
methods that we'll use to discover word
origins specifically at homology
requires an understanding of the parts of
words, their pronunciation
and grammar components.
So you'll need some understanding
of phonology and morphology.
Etymology is also a diachronic process.
What this means is that etymology is a
function of a language is change over
time.
So etymology will make more sense if you,
if you're already versed in the
fundamentals of historical linguistics,
if you're aware of key concepts
like cognates and borrowings,
reconstruction of Poteau languages and
discussions about what is a language and
what is a dialect, we can
start to build etymologies, uh,
for the etymology of a particular word.
We'll need to know about language change
over time in general and the history of
change in a particular
language that we're analyzing.
We'll also need to know the history of
borrowing a bard words are called lone
words or loans, uh, borrowing
into that particular language.
And in turn the historical changes that
those source languages that were the
source of the borrowings underwent.
Notice that words are often borrowed or
inherited from non standard forms of a
language. And that adds to the
complexity. Take for instance,
a medieval Norman French borrowings into
middle English, like the word chief,
which is not the same as the modern French
word chef or the interesting case of
dialect mixing,
which accounts for the word pair,
shirt and skirt in modern English.
So with those complexities in mind,
let's discuss how we trace the path
of a word as it sounded in its form.
Change as much as is possible,
we rely on historical attestation here.
We expect our etymology to account for
the evidence that is the word that we're
tracing as it was actually used
throughout its history. For example,
the modern English word queen goes back
to an earlier Cwayna in middle English.
This word is a tested in Chaucer Quain.
I in turn,
derives from old English
Quain attested in Beowulf.
Here we can say that the Edelman or
source word of queen is the old English
Kwame, but we aren't restricted
by the attested evidence.
There are two ways to trace
a more distant origin. First,
we might discover that a
word was influenced by or
borrowed from another dialect
or another language like English were
chief, which was borrowed from French.
In this case, our etymology can continue
in that source language. Second,
we can increase our time by comparing
related languages and engaging in the
process of historical reconstructions.
A clever intellectual development I
introduced in the lesson on historical
linguistics. Therefore,
as much as possible,
our etymology we'll take into account
the history of borrowing it influence and
will terminate at the earliest
reconstructible form of a word,
not the earliest attested form.
For example,
the old English word Quain can be compared
to other early dramatic words like
the Gothic quaint's or the old Norse
fen allowing us to reconstruct a produce
dramatic ancestral form as Quen is when
we compare the pro dramatic word to
cognates in other nondramatic Indo
European languages like the ancient Greek
word Janae and the Sanskrit [inaudible],
we can begin to reconstruct a pro to
Indo European root like goon or Gwen will
then see that grims law applies to
all Germanic languages, which changed.
Voiceless stops to uh,
fricatives and voice stops to voiceless
stops giving us a route, Quinn,
beginning with the voiceless sound
k rather than the voice, GI or gut.
Know when I said that grims law
applies to all dramatic languages,
that doesn't mean that it
still impacts modern languages,
but like all sound laws,
it effected words at one point in history.
In this case in pro dramatic.
So let's review what we've done here.
We found the earliest attested form of
queen and English compared to two words
in related Germanic languages.
To trace the word to a reconstructed
proto dramatic word and compared produ
dramatic to relate it
into European languages.
To trace the word even further back to
a reconstructed prodo Indo European root
word. Along the way, we paid
attention to sound changes.
Notice that you'll find an asterisk next
to reconstruct it forms and also notice
how the derivational path
is represented visually. Uh,
Gwen is becomes queen,
which becomes Cwayna or
[inaudible] comes from Queen,
which comes from Quinn is
it's also crucial to
understand morphology,
to know what kind of
word you're dealing with.
Especially key here is word formation.
The way affixes are added
to routes to form new words,
which is derivation or how words
are compounded to form new words,
which is compounding. Inflectional
morphemes are certainly considered,
but they're really part of the
grammar or structure of a language.
While etymology often focuses on content,
words or content morphemes.
Um, an example of why morphology
matters when doing etymology,
when we traced the history of Queen, we
arrived at a pro dramatic word. Quen is,
which has an inflectional
suffix is attached to the root.
Now in a separate instance,
you might be doing the etymology
of say the word illogical,
that re that word has a root Logue
and three derivational affixes,
a suffix, a suffix. Oh,
and a prefix in which assimilated too
ill to do justice to the etymology of
these words.
You'll need to understand and know
the derivation of these morphemes.
In the next video,
I'll talk about the role of semantics,
particularly meaning change in etymology.
And I'll also touch on basic conventions
followed when presenting an etymology.
Hope this has been helpful and see them.